[Applause]
this is a big [ __ ] deal was made out
of this and i'm trying to decide whether
or not this actually matters
but lebron jr ronnie
smoking the wheat and i'm curious you're
taking on it oh gosh i'm curious your
take a matter of fact all of you guys
i'm curious your take on it at first i
looked at this and i'm like
it's a 16 year old kid whose parents are
in the bubble
because i think he's literally home
alone
and he's anxious he doesn't respect the
babysitter whoever's looking after him
i'm sorry some family member or
something like that's taking care of him
and what happens a lot of times when
kids are anxious they try to find the
boundaries
they act out waiting for the rule
waiting for the line they can't cross
right um we've all done this everybody
everybody done it right and i'm like
okay that's what we're seeing here not a
big deal
and then i looked in and i go wait a
minute
this kid wants to play ball he wants to
be part of organizations
he's been media trained since he's
[ __ ] two years old he is
abundantly aware it's a big deal of what
this means
and the reaction this will get and
just opinion is a possibility both both
could work right but
emboss and i wonder if
and this might be reaching you push me
back but i wonder
if at six two
sixteen years old
playing okay in high school ball
brawny is maybe starting to realize
uh he might not make the league
and because of that he can start making
self-destruct not necessarily destruct
but like maybe
sabotage not even self-sabotage but more
like i'm gonna make decisions that like
any regular teenager would make that
wouldn't go to the league and smoking a
little weed might be that
right i wonder if that's playing into it
okay thoughts
i would say this i would say even though
he's been media trained since he was two
or whatever you want to call it
he's still 16. and when you see he's and
yeah you do
dumb [ __ ] as a kid even when you know
it's not even oh [ __ ] i didn't even
think about that like
he knows right but also you're like like
you said mom and dad are gone man
you know how much dumb [ __ ] i did when
my parents were gone like on a trip man
[ __ ] man like that's you just do that
and it has nothing to do with like
rich family poor family like great
upbringing
uh you know terrible upbringing and all
that doesn't matter at that age like you
said
you are seeking out what are the
boundaries of the [ __ ] i can do
you're just having fun man it's not a
big deal but
also you gotta understand it wasn't
somebody caught you
on camera smoking your dumbass put your
own
and that's the part what's up yeah but
he
chose to videotape himself not that he
was smoking smoking
i this is no no that's a good point
but another thing that he did is we're
smoking the nugget like
he almost tagged his dad in his own
tweet right i understand how this
happened it's a big deal
yeah i don't know about you guys growing
up in an immigrant family at least
indian immigrant
everything you do reflects upon your
family sure anytime you emba
a kid embarrasses somebody like yo he's
embarrassing his entire family
sure you're a kid you make dumb
decisions but if you're brawny [ __ ]
james
you don't think your decisions reflect
upon your family
with a billion dollar empire and you put
yourself
yo you you're a kid you [ __ ] up but
you [ __ ] up
but hold on but having said all that you
grew up in an immigrant family just like
me i had that same speech and everything
you're not doing dumb [ __ ] i did very
little dumb [ __ ] you did
very much perfect ladies and gentlemen i
did very little dumb [ __ ]
because it reflects upon your family
sure mistakes happen call me
it's a [ __ ] right here this is this is
very
there is potentially tens of millions of
dollars online or whatever
this is lebron [ __ ] james this guy is
a brand
for you to smoke weed put yourself on ig
live
sure do kids do stupid things okay fine
but that doesn't mean
make it not a huge mistake it's a huge
mistake
what's it going to do to him not too
much then this is temporarily
it's not a huge mistake go alex go john
wall
was just bozo throwing up not lebron
james
don't put them in the same conversation
if john wall loses his [ __ ] zigzag
sponsorship at reebok or whatever
don't nobody give a [ __ ] about your
little stupid-ass sneakers nobody wears
but he's in the video you're doing this
was the highlight of your career doing
something in 2009
who cares it's john wall we've been
media trained as kids but our version of
media train is
i'll say respecting adults is respecting
adults we've all
done little things and uh behaved to get
in trouble even though we've been media
trained our whole life to respect adults
and so like maybe you talked in class
clash clown or some [ __ ] like that i got
kicked
out hey you were a kid you were smart
you know that would make your family
uh upset at you but you still do it yeah
yeah
he's just a kid i see how kids make
mistakes but i'm not gonna say oh he's a
kid
no you [ __ ] up no kid you're going to
keep fighting
but it's also not his first ig slip up
he been on ig acting up before
what was the other one no he did like i
remember there was some little [ __ ]
wasn't that big
but that was a small thing that you
could have been like yo someone asked
him he would smash dwyane wade's son
or daughter or whatever the [ __ ] that
ate him he was like yo
chill cut that out that one hey [ __ ] up
he handled that perfectly right yeah
perfect
so what i would say is this there is
something slightly different
in that when you have social media as a
as a person who has like some level of
fame
okay you know the reaction that you get
when you post something there
so for example like when he does a tick
tock where they're doing some dance
together the family
and then it makes sports center it makes
everywhere he knows the ripple effect of
his actions
so that's way more clear to him than it
is some average kid who doesn't have the
spotlight and they don't see
their actions become a national news
story when they do something
so he knows by smoking that it's going
to be on sportscenter
it's going to be on fox sports news it's
going to be on every instagram post
every blog
everything he knows the [ __ ] show that's
going to cost
i'm surprised you didn't go i thought
you were going right for your
wheelhouse which is which is [ __ ] was
involved somehow or another
interesting meaning like
this might be on sportscenter and i'm
gonna get in trouble or
i might impress look at me i'm on a grin
i'm lit
come on all these [ __ ] young rappers
and [ __ ] like that he wants to be a kid
you think he needs help getting [ __ ]
bro yo you're ronnie james
ronnie james needs help getting [ __ ]
bro son but he still wants to look cool
like these little kids look up to these
mumble rappers they all do this [ __ ] i'm
surprised you all got purple hair
yeah i [ __ ] can't wait away with it
you can't get away with it if you are
a billionaire kid you can't get away
with it the way [ __ ] some other kid
could
you are more famous than john wall right
now yeah but look what i can't get away
with that [ __ ] no that's true no but
it's true he could maybe be doing it
just try to impress his friends
he probably trying to get some [ __ ]
from egnon
you